he's in the class  [Music]  everybody if i got shots fired we're  gonna be in the uh the building  the west side  we gotta get in there  we gotta get in there you should we  gotta get in there  [Music]  [Music]  all right we might need help we got  shots fired at the school bro  you got guys inside the classroom right  now  i'm doing for my year  i don't know if you have to come out  here extra help  actually shooting rob school  just give me a heads up maybe i could no  more help the better you  know that day  several officers  in the hallway or in that building  knew  or should have known there was dying in  that classroom and they should have done  more  [Music]  over there  [Music]  you